la comédie française vient d'accueillir
sans nouvel administrateur il s'appelle
jean pierre vincent et sucettes et
succède à jacques toja et à chaque
changement on se demande si le nouveau
venu ne va pas en quelque sorte de
révolutionner la vénérable maison un
théâtre dont les principales
transformations relève seulement jusqu'à
ce jour de relâche de l' architecture
avec la rénovation de la salle richelieu
tout va-t-il changer avec jean pierre
vincent c'est ce qu'a voulu voir jean
jacques dufour en allant flâner dans les
coulisses il n'y aura pas de révolution
de changement spectaculaire dans
l'administration de cette maison
tricentenaire fondée par louis xiv le
19e administrateurs en 130 ans jean
pierre vincent qui fut longtemps
responsable du théâtre national de
strasbourg
ici en train de signer quatre nouveaux
contrats de pensionnaires nous a précisé
qu'il n'était lecture liseret pas à
toute force le travail des comédiens
il veut imposer plus des créations et
décentralisé encore davantage la comédie
française à savoir le fait d'avoir des
relations avec un certain nombre de
théâtres ou d'instruments culturel qui
travaillent en province et que nous
allons fréquentes et non pas sur le mode
des tournées très rapide qui font passer
la comédie française une soirée dans une
ville et puis repartir mais en restant
plusieurs jours dans une ville pour
avoir de profonds contact et avec nos
collègues professionnels de théâtre et
avec les publics juste jusqu'au point de
faire une création même en province
puisque ivanov de tchekhov qui sera
monté par claude régy en fin de saison
aura sa première à nice puis sera joué à
grenoble avant d'être jouée ici dans la
salle richelieu
la saison s'est ouverte il ya quelques
jours avec une reprise
la seconde surprise de l'amour de
marivaux c'est vous qui n'augurait la
saison
peut-être un communicant 16 oui par une
reprise c'est parce que le spectacle a
été créé la saison dernière mais comme
il a très bien marché bien la direction
a décidé de le reprendre pour la rentrée
la salle a surpris alors la seconde
surprise de l'amour et la colonie dans
le même spectacle c'est un ensemble de
marivaux qui va se jouer jusqu'à
décembre mais superficielle un homme qui
sait que sénèque pour garant de ce qu'il
dit ainsi que vous le verrez plupart
pour le 24 août à pitre attaques fusent
chapitre 1000 sénèque ne sait ce qu'il
dit soit impossible à vérifier samedi
vers type plus que ma lecture voilà
c'est votre livre ne plaît pas aux
chevaliers l'horizon plus une autre fois
le seront plus 0 c'est votre goût madame
qui va décider où mon goût veut bien
avoir cette complaisance là pour lourdes
ce n'est qu'un petit auteur je suis fier
c'est joli c'est je crois un
bouleversement quand même la suppression
des soirées habiller une mesure qui
permettra d'offrir quatre fois par mois
des places aux spectateurs sans
abonnement